حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وزاره الصحه في غزه تعلن
ان الاحتلال الاسرائيليه ارتكب 16 مجزره
في القطاع خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه ذهب
ضحيتها 150 شهيدا ونحو
313 جريحا في حين وصف المتحدث وزاره الصحه
في قطاع غزه اشرف القدر الوضع الانساني في
جنوب القطاع بالكارثي وقال في اتصال مع
الجزيره ان فرق الانقاذ غير قادره على
الوصول الى الشهداء
والمصابين تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه
في الرابط الموجود في
التعليقات الامم المتحده تقول ان المعارك
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ادت الى نزوح حوالي 8 ملايين شخص مطالبه
بتوفير دعم عاجل لتلبيه احتياجاتهم اما
سياسيا فقد قال رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان التفاوض لوقف الحرب
ينبغي ان يكون داخل البلاد وانه لابد من
الجلوس مع كل اطياف الشعب للوصول لحلول
مرضيه
للجميع روسيا واوكرانيا تعلنان تبادل نحو
200ي اسير حرب من الجانبين وذلك بعد اسبوع
من تحطم طائره عسكريه روسيه قالت موسكو
انها كانت قل جنودا اوكرانيين اسرى واتهمت
كيف باسقاطه حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان الاسرى الروس تم نقلهم لتلقي
العلاج واعاده التاهيل في موسكو فيحين رحب
زيلنسكي بعوده الاوكرانيين
المحتجزين العفو الدوليه تدعو السلطات
الهنديه الى وقف سياساتها التمييزي ضد
المسلمين والمتمثله بهدم ممتلكاتهم بصوره
عقابيه وذلك بعد ايام من احداث عنف طائف
حرض عليه مشاركون في مسيره هندوسيه حاشده
في مومبي مؤكده ان الاجراءات غير
القانونيه المتخذه ضد اشخاص يشتبه
بارتكابهم اعمال عنف تشكل صفعه كبرى
لسياده القانون الى
اللقاء